Charles J Sykes author of a victim of
nations of the Kay of the American
character what is character when
character is the is the traditional
notion that we ought to engage in
self-restraint that we ought to practice
moderation the values of honesty and
probity the sense of responsibility and
duty to other people a culture of
character is one that basically says
that what what happens to you is
basically your responsibility you were
reliant on yourself and it tends to be a
very archaic notion that I think is
making something of a comeback both in
politics and in public policy a nation
of victims
what kind of victims all kinds of
victims I think that what I argue in the
book is that we've become a nation of
people who say I'm not responsible don't
blame me I'm a victim that when anything
happens to anything bad happens to it to
individuals they quickly turn to
somebody else to blame
whether it's turning to a therapist who
will explain that you are not bad you
are merely the victim of a syndrome or
dysfunction or you find a lawyer who
will find somebody else to sue to put
the responsibility on someone else or
political demagogue who will say you're
not responsible because you have been
oppressed and victimized by others so
I'm describing the phenomenon of our
society which more and more groups seem
to want to get in on what they see is a
good thing to define themselves as a
member of an evict of an aggrieved group
and a member member of a group that has
been oppressed or victimized in some way
and to demand the sort of the moral
innocence of victims and the moral
authority of victims and perhaps even
the entitlements and benefits of being a
member of a victim group you ever felt
like a victim not to not lately no and
if I did I wouldn't admit it we're not I
think that one of the things that that I
get to in the book is that we need a
moratorium on blame is that we all
suffer from injustice there are always
things that are gonna happen to us that
will we feel we've been treated unfairly
but perhaps it's time to stop focusing
on that not to use them as alibis not to
use them as excuses not to build our
identity around blaming other people and
to take some sense of responsibility for
for yourself so I only don't who do you
blame
for us becoming a nation of victims I
see I don't think it's a matter of
blaming other people it's all of our
responsibility it's the fact that
Americans I think have always been a
culture built around the concept of
happiness the pursuit of happiness is
obviously a basic idea in American
culture but I think Americans have
gotten the notion somehow that happiness
is not something that you need to work
for or win or struggle for strive for
that it's an entitlement that we deserve
it that we have a right to it and that
if we don't get all sorts of self
realization self fulfillment good sex
perfect jobs everything that somehow we
have been we are disappointed that we
have been deprived and it's somebody
else's fault for that so to look around
and say that it that it's our government
that has done it or it's the lawyers or
it's any other group
I think misses the point this is a
fundamental cultural phenomenon in which
we all participate to a greater or
lesser extent you're the offeror author
of profit scam what was that well that
was a critique of American higher
education that talked about the flight
from teaching on the part of academia
the the whole the whole notion that many
young people go to colleges spend a lot
of money under the impression they will
be getting professors in the classroom
in fact they don't Martin Anderson has
written a book that it really follows up
on that theme quite well but that was a
critique of the whole academic culture
the culture in which research often
abstract and pointless had was
considered more important than teaching
and the decline of liberal education
that that flows from that we've got the
maddest at you for writing that book
people got the maddest were were the
practitioners of the the academic gurus
the the tenured professors who felt that
that I was challenging the dearest
values of it but on the other hand there
are a lot of academics and I think of a
surprising number of people who teach in
universities and in smaller schools who
are genuinely committed to teaching who
really see their role as teaching and
who saw that book as as helping them in
their effort that that people who were
troubled by the emphasis on bogus
scholarship who were
troubled by the political pressures that
they face to get out of the classroom
and one of the reasons that book was so
successful was because I think it spoke
to the needs of that kind of faculty
member as well as as students and
parents where do you left Milwaukee
what do you do well I write books like
this I am a senior fellow at the
Wisconsin Policy Institute where I added
a public policy journal among other
things
what's the Wisconsin Policy Institute
it's a public policy think-tank
headquartered were in Milwaukee who pays
for it I think a lot of donors it gets a
significant foundation support I think
the Bradley Foundation has been very
supportive of it what's the Bradley
Foundation Elli foundation is a very
very large foundation involved in public
policy issues that was basically funded
from the sale of Allen Bradley to the
Rockwell Corporation but is one of the I
think leading leading foundations in the
country in terms of funding of academic
and policy undertakings how many people
work there I have no idea where you are
you know Oh at the Wisconsin Policy
Institute it's relatively small there's
a handful of senior fellows which I am
one of two I think and you have a
certain political bent well I try to
avoid being labeled I generally deny
that I am a conservative I describe
myself as a recovering liberal and you
can interpret that however however you
like but I tend to find that labels are
more misleading than they are helpful
because I think they tend to pigeonhole
and on in this book I try to draw from
people from a wide variety of political
perspectives and I think that the
critique applies to people at both ends
of the political spectrum I think that
conservatives often play the the blaming
other people game just as much as
liberals wears hometown originally well
I've lived in Milwaukee for quite a long
time I was born in Seattle and spent
some of my younger years in the New York
area have you ever been involved in
politics yes sort of tangentially I but
my my wife is the is the is the office
holder she's an elected official in
Milwaukee she's a criminal court judge
is it a partisan job no and when you
were involved tangentially would you
work for well my first campaign is a
teenager was in 1968 for Eugene
McCarthy that my father was the campaign
manager for Eugene McCarthy and I was a
page the 1968 Democratic National
Convention down in Chicago that
nominated Hubert Humphrey your father
was the campaign manager in Wisconsin or
dryish Bergkamp Freddie in Wisconsin
Wisconsin primary and how did he get to
that position he was active in the
anti-war movement back in the 60s he was
a 1960s liberal and he contacted the
McCarthy campaign and said I want to
help and I want to do this and I had
this teenage son and he and I will set
up the campaign for you if you like him
which is what we did what happened to
Eugene McCarthy in that Wisconsin well
it started off small it started off my
my father and I in one little room in
the Wisconsin hotel and by the end of
course it became the Children's Crusade
and Eugene McCarthy of course one which
was helped by the fact that two days
before the primary Lyndon Johnson
withdrew from the from the campaign and
my father and I were traveling with
Eugene McCarthy that weekend when when
Lyndon Johnson pulled out of the race
what did you learn from gene McCarthy
well I learned from Eugene McCarthy I
think Eugene McCarthy was one of the
most decent honest eloquent men ever to
seek office and that I think that he
I've learned how far short so many other
politicians uh fall from that but he was
a man of principle a man who I think who
genuinely was concerned about dealing
with social problems rather than
striking a moral pose
I don't think gene McCarthy had the idea
that he wanted programs that would make
him feel good and compassionate he
wanted things that would actually work
work for anybody else after that not
that I can recall now where'd you go
school the University of
wisconsin-milwaukee
or did you study English literature and
when you what started to get this book
together how did you go about it well
this book sort of grew out of some of
the the research that I had done on
higher education I'd written profs qiyam
and The Hollow Men The Hollow Men
dealing more with the politics of higher
education and I was struck by how much
the politics on campus had become kind
of a victims Olympics who is the biggest
victim who is the most oppressed and the
way in which that was driving the
political discussion in the debate how
the various groups tend to be vulcanized
themselves as they slice themselves
into narrower and narrower interest
groups defined primarily by their status
of oppression as I looked around I
realized this was hardly confined to the
campus hardly confined to the inner city
that in fact it seemed to be something
that more and more Americans like
watching ripple ripples in a pond
there's more and more groups the the
middle-aged decided they were victims to
millionaire artists decided they were
victims to the list of racism sexism
homophobia you were seeing talk about
ageism lookism so when I started working
on it I sort of started from what was
happening that I had seen on campus but
then tried to make it a more broader
cultural phenomenon and I tried to
determine where this would come from and
where it came from and one of the first
things that I determined was that just
look at the strictly in terms of
politics to say that its left versus
right misses I think the underlying
cultural phenomenon that we're seeing
that that's something deeper in the
American character is going on and that
drove the research from there let me
pull up a bunch of stuff out of here
especially when it comes to universities
you write at the University of Michigan
students face discipline for suggesting
that women were not as qualified as men
in any given field one student was
actually brought up on charges of sexual
harassment for suggesting that he could
develop a counseling plan for helping
gays become straight right and I'm not
endure the point is not to endorse those
comments or that program what I thought
was extraordinary about that was that in
an institution built on the concept of
intellectual freedom and academic
freedom that you had these gag rules and
the point was that the issue of women
being qualified was not to be subject to
debate they didn't want arguments pro
and con it was banned and it was banned
on the grounds that it would perhaps
hurt someone's feelings they would be
insensitive and I guess this is one of
my starting points which is that if if
free speech if speech is only as free as
the most hypersensitive group on campus
will permit if you're not going to have
very much free speech particularly as
they the climate on campus was that more
and more groups were becoming more and
more hypersensitive what I saw was that
you would see these in visit
tripwires of grievance being spread all
over the campus with rules like this the
University of Connecticut banned
inappropriate laughter and you have to
ask yourself what's going on here and
and one of the things that I concluded
was that the whole therapeutic culture
of our society that said we're not bad
but we're sick had somehow it taken on a
political tone that we no longer engaged
in a debate of ideas but that we use the
sensitivity training model as to govern
to govern speech in the Central City
training model basically says we're not
going to argue and discuss something I'm
going to cure you of attitudes that are
by definition inappropriate to me I
thought it was a tremendous departure
from the universities but again would
not have been possible unless you had
didn't have other millions of Americans
who in fact were going to self-help
groups learning to be sensitive that and
and defining behavior in these medical
therapeutic terms but this is basically
where it leads to at the University of
Minnesota for example cheerleaders have
been banned from performing at sporting
events on the grounds that their
routines foster sexual stereotypes
demeaning to the dancers yes still well
the the dancers by the way did not feel
that they were victims they felt they
were performers and this was part of the
extension of victims status where people
were out there looking for groups that
ought to feel they were oppressed even
if they weren't oppressed and so the
these these women were banned from it
even though they signed a letter saying
we don't feel the mean we don't feel
victimized so it was sort of a a a
outreach effort to convince more and
more people that they are victims and
this is a quite a phenomenon in
university campuses William and Mary
insisting the term kingpin be changed to
keep person and that unwed mother be
replaced with the non judgmental mother
well I think there's a whole list of
words and phrases that that have been
deemed to be inappropriate the
University of Missouri School of
Journalism came out with a rather famous
list of politically incorrect terms
again trying to trying to sensitize
language to the point where where it
would be totally inoffensive now there's
nothing wrong with sensitivity
we all want to be sensitive sensitivity
is the mark of a civil and civilized
society but at some point a culture
built on hypersensitivity will be one in
which we're not asked to adhere to
mutually agreed-upon standards of
justice and fairness as political
sensitivity means if I'm a victim
you must attune yourself to all of the
shifting shades of emotional grievance
that I might feel and because only a
victim can understand the victims pain
only I can define it and so you sort of
have this rolling standard of
sensitivity that became I think quite
ironically that sensitivity became the
banner under which there was a good deal
of browbeating going on and I think has
contributed to this tone of intolerance
on many university campuses there's a is
it shal ala
is that the delaila shillelagh the donna
shillelagh who is the Chancellor of the
University of wisconsin-madison you went
to Milwaukee right okay
she said you caught her saying I would
plead guilty to both racism and sexism
the university is institutionally racist
American Society is racist and sexist
she's also been in the middle of a
controversy about politically correct
speech and right explain that well Donna
shillelagh is is representative of a
certain kind of academic that that
engages in the kind of self flagellation
you know feeling guilty all the time and
using that as an excuse for example at
the University of Wisconsin to impose a
gag rule a limp limits on free speech
that were in place until a federal judge
reminded Donna shillelagh and other
officials of the university that they
were not exempt from the First Amendment
and I think part of the there's an
inherent contradiction in some of these
policies because the assumption of gag
rules and the sensitivity training is
that while you and I for example
consider and engage in a vigorous
exchange of ideas and debate and perhaps
disagree with one another vigorously
that certain groups victim group - that
women or minorities are to be considered
frail psychological growth so frail that
they could be blighted or their
self-esteem destroyed by the slightest
word
or expression or idea that they might
find uncongenial now the problem with
that is is that the people who are
pushing that line will sometimes argue
that it's necessary to do that in order
to build or enhance the self-esteem of
these victim groups well I'm not sure
how you can build self-esteem by
starting off feeling that these groups
the members of these victim groups are
so disabled that they need to be
protected against all of that you can't
somehow go from feeling frail and
psychologically vulnerable to somehow
getting to the point of empowerment and
self-esteem that people would claim for
it so that's the kind of what I call the
sort of a double-edged sword
of victimization in which which you are
trying to enhance the self-esteem or the
stature of someone while simultaneously
explaining all the ways in which they
are unable to function in a normal
environment according to Professor
Robert Raven whites do not need any
protection from abusive language because
they do not have a history of being
discriminated against only those who
have been victims of oppression need to
be shielded from offensive words right
is he I think he's the professor's here
the president Stanford this is one of
those arguments that would that would
argue that in fact that only only
White's can be racist there is no such
thing as black racism so therefore when
you have a speech code only a white
could violate it no black students can
and that this is a very good example of
when you start to have the politics of
victimization because rather than have
rules that insist upon fairness that
have a level playing field you get into
the categorization of individuals on the
basis of their status for example a
member of this group is cannot be
charged with it so what I suggest you
become getting a sliding rule of
victimization if blacks cannot be racist
what about Italians what about Irish
what about the Hispanics do you have to
have a sort of a gradation of who is the
most victimized and if you are
victimized who can you slur or not slur
a it's perhaps time to get back to a
more fundamental basis that Martin
Luther King talked about that we ought
to be judged not by the color of our
skin but by the content of our character
which is of course
title of Shelby Steel's book because
once you get away from dealing with
individuals as human beings and what we
have in common and you start
apportioning rights and benefits on the
basis of who is the most victimized
you're going to have quite a rush to
determine who is the most oppressed and
you get rather absurd arguments that
sometimes occur on campuses but who can
be racist and who can't be racist you
also quote here a professor I believe
from Brown
Donald Cal right he is a sensitivity
trainer hired by Brown who openly
acknowledged that his goal was to
convince his audience that America is a
racist society in which privileged
White's have established arbitrary norms
of acceptable behavior right this is
part of the outreach program that you
often find on campuses which is that
students may come to an elite university
like brown thinking well you know life
is treating me pretty well I mean I'm
one of the finest universities in the
country and extraordinary efforts are
steps are taken to convince them that in
fact despite perhaps their middle-class
background despite having scholarships
despite being at this wonderful place in
Providence Rhode Island that in fact
they are victims that they are oppressed
and that's one example since we probably
won't rid our society of racism until
everyone strives to be abnormal
well it's heed the previous sentences he
says that that if you are behaving
normally you're probably oppressing
somebody and unfortunately that creates
the hypersensitivity once again though I
sympathize with minority students on
campus because I think you need to
imagine if you were sent to a strange
environment and you were told by the way
mr. Lam everyone you're gonna meet
dislikes you they are prejudiced against
you they don't think you're very good
and you're gonna fight it in all sorts
of subtle ways I mean they may act nice
to your face but really they think you
don't belong here now if I put you in a
room with people and you believe that
you would look around you would feel
very uncomfortable and you would begin
to interpret all sorts of very subtle
signs as confirmations perhaps of this
so I think there's it becomes kind of a
of a rolling system of victimization
where you convince people that they are
victims and
when they begin to feel victimized you
can demands but specific protections but
as steel shall be steel pointed out the
author of a content of our character the
the problem with with this sort of thing
is that there's a certain power to being
a victim the sense of moral innocence
and moral authority and there are
certain political benefits to being a
victim these days but ultimately it is a
victims power and there's a real problem
with yoking your identity or and your
power to your status as a victim because
you are also then yoking it to your
sense of disability to your sense of
being left out and if you constantly
tell young minorities that they are in a
world that is inhabited by invisible
demons that are always out to get them
that in fact that the deck is stacked
against them whatever they turn that
people are always going to undermine
them that this is going to have a
self-fulfilling prophecy in some way
which is not to deny that racism is not
a problem
it's not to deny that there's not
discrimination it is to suggest that
perhaps it is not always helpful to
emphasize the the oppression and racism
to the exclusion of all other factors
who's John Bradshaw John Bradshaw is one
of the Guru's of I suppose the one
through the recovery movement the best
known for his public television
broadcast in his books where he talks
about the the injured inner child within
all of us and the the other category
sides the political ones we've been
discussing has been as I say in the book
the the rise of the therapeutic culture
the sense that depending on how you
define behavior and the normal problems
of life we can all be considered
dysfunctional now Bradshaw is more
aggressive about this than almost
anybody else they've never seen him just
add some things that you write about him
here you say as recipients of Bradshaw's
quote treatment unquote grown men and
women sit around holding teddy bears
listening to a maternal heartbeat while
Bradshaw urges them to imagine
themselves back in the womb and infants
as infants excuse me his message is is
whispered to the inner child over and
over quote you are perfect in every way
love you just the way you are welcome to
the world I'm so glad you're here I've
been waiting for you and I've prepared a
very special place for you I love you
just the way you are you have all the
time you need to have your needs met
there wouldn't that be great if that was
the case wouldn't it be greatest every
day we went to the office we had that
sort of thing how does that like this
I'm John Bradshaw and I don't maybe you
know a lot more about him get a program
on public television and what's the
purpose of it because he does touch a
deep need in in people one of the things
that Bradshaw says is that something
like over 90% of all families can be
considered dysfunctional he's been
quoted as saying that which basically
means that all of us in some sense can
blame somebody else for our problems
mommy and daddy are a good target but
also we all want to be loved and we
would wish that everything was was was
suited for us that that all of our needs
were taken care of
that's what it was like when we were
babies and you know part of the problem
in American culture is that Americans
are very ambivalent about growing up you
know we know that we have to do it but
we don't necessarily like it somebody
like Bradshaw says is not only are your
needs more important than anybody else's
needs but the needs of your injured
inner child should come first and for a
society that wants has extraordinary
expectations and thinks that happiness
is an entitlement
this definitely touches a chord although
I'm not necessarily sure again that the
road to full self-esteem is really
appropriately reached by thinking of
oneself as an infant do you know
anything about Brad John Bradshaw oh yes
but where's he come from oh I'll be do
about his betters background noise
there's biographical you watching that
yes yes I was he has a tremendous impact
it's interesting if if you a Americans
seem to have a tremendous capacity to
feel sorry for themselves and defend to
parade their injuries this is again part
of perhaps of the therapeutic culture
let me read a little bit more here on
his TV show he gets one of the biggest
laughs when he ridicules the nuns who
instructed him in grade school who
claimed to have quote actual picture of
hell however amused they may be by such
religious flummery Bradshaw's audiences
nonetheless accept without question is
equally mystical
of the womb and of infancy in which all
needs are met all demands satisfied all
anxieties allayed that's right and again
it well you know I there's no question
about it that the therapeutic vision of
society tends to be a substitute
religion in its in some sense and you
know as I said he gets a laugh by
talking about the vision of hell and he
creates this equally mythical vision of
what the womb would be like what
everything was was perfect and we're do
people like Joseph Campbell who used to
be on public television and I think
you're still seeing all those to see and
Robert Fulghum who you can see there
what are their messages do you follow
them well no not it's not a visit
they're not exactly along the same lines
I mean they they use myths in in
different ways when I say that the
Bradshaw's approaches is is mythical I
mean saying that basically he's making
it up that is creating a sense of
absolute innocence and Americans are
Europeans often think of Americans is
suffering from radical innocence and I
think that John Bradshaw is the latest
exemplar of that you mentioned Michael
Deaver and John Hinckley and San
Francisco supervisor Dan White and
Robert Alton Harris and you mentioned
though that in mr. Hankey's case it was
insanity and mr. Davis case alcoholism
and mr. White's case twinkies mr.
Harris's case fetal alcohol syndrome
what are you getting at well the I think
that's from the chapter called the
abolition of sin we're not we're not
guilty we're just sick you go into any
courtroom in the country and people say
I'm not responsible for my behavior this
made me do it fill in the blank X and it
sometimes does work because again we are
as a society are much more comfortable
with saying that someone is sick and was
saying they are evil or have done
something bad the whole concept of sin
has been replaced by this these medical
complexes so in every courtroom it has
become you you'll find every courthouse
in the country you'll find someone
saying in my hometown in Milwaukee for
example teenage girl shoots another
teenage girl for her coat lawyer comes
in says my defense would be cultural
psychosis that that because she grew up
in the inner city and poverty she should
not be held responsible for her behavior
and this is
this is part of the flight from from
responsibility in American society now
Jeffrey Dahmer's from the world yes you
bring him up and yes look who did they
blame in that situation well Jeffrey
Dahmer was was before a judge in
Milwaukee two years before his his
ultimate arrest he was charged with
sexually molesting a young layin boy and
the DA said this is a dangerous person
this is someone who shows no remorse who
ought to be sent to prison and the judge
said well I know you want me to send him
to prison but I want him to get therapy
I want him to get help and as a result
gave him a very light sentence and of
course everybody knows the rest and I
guess I guess it's part of the the
adjustment that we need to make that
there are people who suffer from genuine
mental illness but that tends to be
trivialized I think when you have people
who say that well the reason I murdered
the mayor of San Francisco is I ate too
many Twinkies the reason that I made
obscene phone calls was because I was
abused as a child we can come up with an
almost infinite variety of excuses to
basically get away from the point that
we ought to be held accountable and and
there's a certain dignity to this by the
way that if we assume that people do act
on the basis of free will freely chosen
decisions we may come to conclusion
they've done something bad but we've at
least given them the dignity of human
beings whereas by saying that no it's
not your fault you can't be blamed you
were sick
this was not something that you did but
that happened to you we tend to reduce
people to something less than human I
think you mentioned both governor Donald
Schaefer in the state of Maryland right
close by here and former governor
Richard Celeste in Ohio who both
commuted sentences for what reason and
why did you bring it up well this is
again the the the multiplication of
therapeutic categories to explain
behavior and this in in those two
gentlemen's case it was the battered
woman syndrome women who had murdered
their husbands and are arguing that they
should not be held responsible for it
because they suffer from this new
syndrome which is very fashionable and
popular these days unfortunately after
the the commutations in some cases it
came out that one woman I think had
hired someone to murder her husband for
the insurance money
some women had not seen their husband
for a very long time but
the last contact and the murder and I
think that we ought to be a little bit
skeptical of that there's a very
dramatic case since then in down in
Tennessee where a woman police went to a
woman's house found a 13 month old baby
in early stages of decomposition the
other children starving in the in the
household and arrested the husband and
the wife and the woman writes love
letters to the husband while she's in
jail describing various sex acts they
would perform but when she came to trial
the defense used was the battered woman
syndrome in other words at some point
you get excuses on excuses where this
woman's child abuse and perhaps the
willful causing of her children's death
now is being explained by something else
again I think it was very helpful for
society to keep in mind that it ought to
act as if we are responsible for our
behavior because it does only in that
way can we uphold some sense of of
what's right and what's wrong some sense
of moral order which is there's really
no excuse for women to let their
children starve to death
the rights revolution e pluribus victim
is the title of one of your chapters you
quote someone by the name of Fred Segal
who's he you know yes he said he's a
very well-known historian who's written
extensively on the 1960s more and more
dependent on the courts liberals forgot
how to talk to most Americans you quote
mr. Segal as saying how come all right
well I think that part of the the shift
after the the civil rights movement was
instead of instead of seeking to build
coalitions instead of relying on the
tremendous moral force that had been
built up in the 60s was the choice to
use litigation as the tool of choice in
order to advance causes and the rights
revolution is basically again a very
American phenomenon Americans believe
that that if some rights are good as a
good thing then more rights must be a
better thing and if the louder and the
more uncompromising yarn demanding our
rights must be the best of all and as a
result what we've seen is the
proliferation of rights that are not
necessarily linked with responsibilities
that are demanded in a very
uncompromising fashion and I quote a
Harvard Law Professor Mary Ann Glendon
who talks about the new Lange
of Rights which he calls rights talk
which she says you know is tends to be
shrill an absolutist insistence though
on all of our rights with the near
aphasia concerning personal
responsibility and that is clearly one
of the major factors in developing the
culture we have today what do you
ascribe the success of Susan Faludi book
backlash well I'd hate I'd hate to
speculate on that I think one of the one
of the difficult problem in us face to
very difficult problems one is that most
women in this country don't support
their agenda so therefore when they talk
about the women's agenda and the women's
standpoint they have a built-in
political problem the second major
problem that they have to deal with is
to continue to insist that women are
victims in the face of a lot of evidence
to the contrary
for example the massive changes doors
open for women in in the media in
politics in law and engineering and
business over the last twenty years
which have been really extraordinary
those those developments so there is a
very shrill attempt now which is I think
it's somewhat paradoxical given these
successes given the political successes
of women to insist that despite all of
this women are still oppressed they are
still victimized there are all kinds of
plots and counter-revolutions going on
that will keep you in your place so
again it's part of the politics of
victimization where you become yoked to
your victim status and you have to cling
to your victim status and believe in
your victim status even when it looks
like the world is rolling out a red
carpet for you and I think her book is a
perfect example of that I hope a very
tough one but what kind of criminal
judge state write state crime run fraud
or yes elected is she a feminist you'd
have to ask her that I don't know how
she would describe herself you ever talk
about this stuff about victims
yeah well that's that's that's right and
again after on so sue me
that's right well she's in the criminals
yes yes as a the litigation explosion in
this country there's no question about
it that lawyers play a significant role
in that does she hear me of you when you
why does she hear a lot of blame and
when the the victims are people that
come before the court yeah III think
that it's become it's become reflexive
that even even people who may lack high
school education people who would think
are barely literate can explain in great
detail all of the ways that they should
not be held responsible for their
behavior it seems to be the one thing
that we have succeeded in transmitting
to all classes of society your book and
of course the one before profs cam takes
you around the country assume yes is
there any difference in other parts of
the country from Milwaukee and the
attitude with these issues I mean what
do you find as you travel around well I
think I haven't done much traveling on
this particular book but American
society is becoming far more uniform
than it used to be I would say that
there's very there's no part of the
country that's immune from this I mean
there's no part of the country in which
there is not a proliferation of new
therapies there's no part of the country
in which there's not an explosion of
litigation and there's no part of the
country in which you can't find groups
that it really absolutely convinced that
they too are oppressed and victimized
you've got some statistics here 1970 the
EEOC the Equal Employment Opportunity
Commission received 15,000 complaints in
73 the number 8 risen to 48,000 900 in
77 that never tops 79 thousand how did
what was the when did it start do you
remember well I think again the rights
revolution began in the late 1960s and
extended through the 1970s and really
didn't catch fire until they until the
1970s and when it became acceptable
again this is a cultural shift because
discrimination did not get worse in fact
there's probably some evidence that it
got less bad it became more acceptable
in fact even correct to file lawsuits to
blame other people for for the situation
now this is not to deny I understand the
discrimination is a reality that racism
is a reality the point to be made here
is that at some point there's a
Gresham's law of victimization which is
that bogus victims drive out real
victims
that you know if everybody's a victim
nobody's a victim so that not only do
you have people who are genuine victims
of racial discrimination but you have
like for example the case of the flasher
which I described in in Wisconsin
man there's convicted of flashing more
than exposing himself more than 30 times
by his own admission and done about
10,000 times applies for a job as a park
attendant he's denied the job based on
his arrest record he sues saying he'd
been illegally discriminated against
because he had never actually exposed
himself in a park only in libraries and
laundromats and the Equal Employment
Commission in Wisconsin found that
indeed he had a there's probable cause
to believe that he had in fact been
discriminated against so again we have a
dramatic expansion of our definition of
discrimination as well as a greater
willingness to to it to litigate it say
that there'd be 40,000 graduates of law
schools this year I think that's true
yes I read it again and see you know in
the 1990s law schools will turn out
forty thousand new attorneys a year
there's over six hundred thousand
attorneys in the country yeah why does
this country have more attorneys than
anybody else well we are certainly not
there's some debate of course over the
number of whether we really have 70% of
the native the world's lawyers or not
that's really not important numbers not
terribly important one thing I think is
quite clear as we are not deprived of
lawyers now some people would blame all
of this that I've been describing on
lawyers I they clearly have a good deal
of responsibility but I think they're
also responding to this cultural impulse
I think the I think it was the economist
from the English magazine The Economist
that said that you know Americans act as
if they should receive a life long
indemnification against anything going
wrong that any time anything bad happens
to a to Americans one of the first
things they do is is call us call up a
lawyer so in a sense the lawyers may be
encouraging the flood of litigation but
they're also responding to something in
American society if Americans really
felt that litigation was the court of
last resort if it was something that
they looked upon with disdain or
distaste I don't think even having twice
as many lawyers would result in in the
flood that we experience today
you mentioned television and you quote
Louis Sullivan as
that the three major networks will
depict more than 10,000 sexual
incidences in 93 percent of them outside
of marriage what impact does that have
well I think that of course it's it's
it's debatable what what impact it has
but I don't think there's any question
that that the television tends to both
reflect but but primarily shape social
attitudes I think that sex is obviously
far more common on on screen than off
screen and no wonder people feel that
they're not leading fulfilled lives
because the you know they're probably
not getting as much as they see on on
prime-time but I think that in the
context that he said it is we need to
get back to a culture of character where
people need to we need to emphasize
responsibility as much as self
gratification and we really have
emphasized gratification that really
anything you want to do if it feels good
go ahead and do it there shouldn't be
any consequences to it
for all those sex acts that you see on
television how many result in pregnancy
how many result in children being born
out of wedlock how how many of them do
we see being being dealt with Murphy
Brown aside and in a culture in which
for example in Wisconsin 80 percent of
the black children this year will be
born out of wedlock this has contributed
drastically to the rise of inner-city
poverty to the development of the
underclass to the breakdown of the
community and again I think that we need
to begin to emphasize the fact that
personal responsibility and
accountability have to factor in this
and we ought not to look for a lot of
excuses for this sort of behavior when
did this start when did all of it start
yeah the victim the the nation of
victims and can you go back and put a
date on it no no I can't you can do that
you can go back 30 years or well I think
really picking up you know I think that
is it's clearly something that's
occurred after the nineteen fifties even
but even Alexis de Tocqueville a hundred
years ago wrote about the vague dread
among Americans who are constantly
brooding over the advantages that they
didn't possess even though they were
much better shape than their European
counterparts Americans have always had a
certain level of anger
xiety have always kind of worried about
you know not getting everything they
possibly can out of life but I think
that you have you have four factors that
have occurred really since the 1950s in
the 60s the first is as I described the
extraordinarily heightened expectations
that Americans have that we moved from
emphasizing self-control to emphasizing
self-realization self fulfillment and
the belief that we could have it all
number two would be the rights
revolution that we've just talked about
the more rights the better third would
be the depersonalization of blame
whether it is to say you're not bad you
are sick the rise of this therapeutic
culture and at the same time the shift
of blame from the individual to society
and the fourth would be a very specific
thing that happened in the late 60s and
early 1970s which was the bolivia
through the courts and through
legislation the practice of giving
specific entitlements and benefits to
people if they could identify themselves
as part of a victimized group in other
words that the entitlements do not
necessarily go to individuals but to
members of groups therefore providing an
incentive for individuals and groups to
say well we are also victimized and one
one result of that is and I quote one
expert as or pundit as estimated if you
add up now in 1992 all of the groups
that now feel they are oppressed and
victimized would come to three hundred
and seventy four percent of the total
American population in the beginning of
your book and your preface you name a
number of things I just want to ask you
who they are we talked earlier about the
Wisconsin Policy Institute you also
received support from the John am Olin
foundation who's Jon Hamm Oland well the
Johnny Nolan foundation has is again a
foundation involved with with public
policy and a variety of issues and the
president is William Simon the former
secretary of the Treasury do you go to
them personally and ask for money is
that how this works yes what what do
they want from him and is there a
certain point of view that they demand
no actually that's the wonderful thing
about dealing with with them I wrote
them a proposal I said this is the book
that I'm interested in writing and I
would appreciate your support and
and and they they were kind of generous
enough to provide that's when you get
support like from them do they give you
money to get you the book written and
then you also write a contract with
somebody and then you get the proceeds
from that right yeah I don't they don't
get involved in the proceeds no not at
all
you also mentioned here the
intercollegiate Studies Institute what
is that well it's an organization that
deals with college campuses that they
had arranged for a tour of college
campuses to discuss some of my previous
books profs cam in the Holloman and they
enabled me to go to various colleges and
to talk and to get some sense of what
was going on and they provide speakers
and publications for for students and
faculty members on a variety of issues
on college campuses when did you do this
about a year or so ago how many schools
did you go to for ISI I think of
probably about a dozen and what kind of
reaction did you get from the students
well Isis for profs can say well this is
more for the Hollow Men this was talking
about the more the political aspect and
the people that generally showed up for
those speeches were generally were
generally sympathetic this was during
the period where political correctness
was very much in the news and public
consciousness was heightening to it and
that the points that I was making were
where basically that you know it's a
mistake to divide this issue to see this
is a liberal or conservative issue
because what's at stake here are the
values of of liberal education free
speech and tolerance and I said this is
what's at stake and I think there should
be common ground for people of a variety
of ideologies so I think that people who
might have fought that I was coming in
to deliver a conservative critique of
left-wing politics were what were either
surprised and perhaps disappointed
because I think that this was a rather
more basic issue than that let me go
back and get the dates correct profs cam
was written what year it was published
in 1988 Hollow Men was published in what
year 1990 and this one was published
this year right 1982 the intercollegiate
Studies Institute who supports that and
where's it headquartered and what kind
of people do they send all over the
country
that's a good question they're
headquartered in Bryn Mawr Pennsylvania
they're supported by it's a good
question I'm not sure I imagine that
they get foundation support and I think
they tend to be very very specifically
conservative and do they pay you to go
to these campuses or to the campuses pay
the other they usually they have a grant
the I is I had a grant from the Olin
foundation to send me to the campuses
you mentioned that my friend attorney
Julie M Buchanan who's unselfishly
opened her files to me what files
who is she well she is a an attorney who
deals with issues like employment
discrimination and sexual harassment
usually on the defense side and helped
walk me through the sort of the
nightmare of litigation that would be I
think would be is bizarre for most lay
people like myself and was quite helpful
in sort of pointing out what was going
on in in in the law the way that there
were more and more frivolous lawsuits
and the cost that that imposed on the
economy and on business you know
speaking of lawyers again early in the
book you say that in 1991 the United
States had 281 lawyers per 100,000
population that England had 82 for
100,000 population and there were a mere
11 per 100,000 in Japan in this country
281 in Japan 11 what's the difference
have you studied the difference between
the societies and why why so few lawyers
in Japan well I think it there's a very
different attitude towards litigation in
those countries it's a very different
attitude towards the relationship of
individuals and the relationship of
groups to one another let's face it the
Japanese have a culture that really
still emphasizes a communal purpose that
emphasizes self control and self and
self limitation and they're just not a
society it would be very hard for
example to imagine the case that
occurred in New York happening in Japan
the men who engage in the refridgerator
races I talked about in the book Carrie
refrigerators on their back and races
and a couple of them hurt their back and
they turn around they sue the
manufacturer of the refrigerator for
failing to have warnings that you're not
supposed to do this now it's kind of
hard to imagine that happening in Japan
they
I I don't know if they won but the
gentleman there's another case in that
where guy did win in New York gets drunk
jumps in front of a subway train is
mangled when he Sobers up he sues the
subway company for failing to stop in
time in wins of $650,000 judgment again
I think the Japanese still have a
culture based on shame where they have a
sense of I think they would be ashamed
to do it and whereas we in this country
have learned that it's that we shouldn't
feel guilty we shouldn't feel ashamed we
should get in touch with our feelings
and and realize that in fact we're okay
in I'm okay and you're okay you choose a
quote from the British magazine
Economist in which the quote is if you
lose you well the Economist noted with
bemusement
that in the United States if you lose
your job you can sue for the mental
distress of being fired if your bank
goes broke the government has uninsured
or has insured excuse me your deposits
if you drive drunk and Christ
you can sue somebody for failing to warn
you to stop drinking there is always
somebody else to blame do they not have
this problem in England well I think
that this is something that the abroad
people look at the Americans and they
and they are they're really struck by it
and one of the tones you asked by Japan
before to get back to that the Japanese
really do have a sense that America is
our whiner
Americans are whiners look at the the
auto companies for example I mean we
talked about the nation of victims it's
easy of course to focus on politically
correct groups and members of minority
groups but I think it's also interesting
to look at the way American auto
manufacturers deal with their problems
the first thing they do is they they
begin finger-pointing blaming somebody
else it's not our fault the Japanese the
British the French and the Germans
they've picked up on this they recognize
this and and it is it is one of the most
common complaints that you'll hear
abroad about Americans and I think
they're more sensitive to it than we are
because we've sort of gotten used to the
finger-pointing the New York Mets have
hired a psychiatrist well they did in
the late 1980s why well apparently they
decided it wasn't enough to have coaches
deal with the fundamentals of hitting
and pitching and running the bases they
apparently thought that it was important
for players to get in touch with their
inner selves or or for the coach could
the coaches to be able to relate to them
I use that as an example of the triumph
of what of the of the therapeutic
culture in in this country the way that
we have turned over larger and larger
spheres of life to the the
psychotherapist psychoanalyst that where
we have redefined behavior there used to
be thought of in terms of normal
behavior and character in in medical
terms so for example we've developed
therapies for everything from
procrastination overeating overwork
people who spend all their money are no
longer merely no longer merely wasteful
and irresponsible they can suffer from
something called compulsive shopping
syndrome for which there are therapies
and and self-help groups if you gamble
away all of your money you're no longer
a bum you may suffer from compulsive
gambling syndrome
complete with therapies and and
self-help groups so as again it's part
of this transformation of society that
in which all of us can can find a couch
to lie on to explain that we're not bad
we really are misunderstood if you had
to pick a period in history that you
could live in where there was not much
blame and people didn't feel like
victims what would it be well I'm not
trying to be nostalgic here of saying
that there's some gold and era in the
past I think the the important thing is
to find some way of blending together
the genuine understanding and compassion
for the disadvantaged and people who
need it which i think we have now with
with a more traditional notion that we
ought not to throw out concepts of
accountability and responsibility that
perhaps we ought to emphasize things
like self-restraint moderation Duty
responsibility those are not simply 19th
century Victorian ideas they could be
very valuable today and but I think it
would be naive to suggest that there was
some great golden age in the past you
say black Americans are now beginning to
understand the price they have paid for
adopting the values of a cultural and
intellectual elite an elite that has not
always shared with them the tragic
consequences of their ideas what do you
mean well I think it's very interesting
people who regard themselves as
compassionate explaining explaining for
example why it is that minority should
not be held to the same standards as
other people why you can't expect young
black people young black men and women
to stay in school why you can't expect
them to stay off of gangs and things
like that they make these sorts of
excuses that they would never make for
their own children that they would never
in their own lives provide that kind of
a standard where they have for example
they'll glorified the the culture of
self-fulfillment do whatever feels good
but they lived their middle-class lives
they can go off to Harvard and Stanford
whereas in Anacostia and Watts the same
sort of moral values have a much more
tragic consequence in 1960s we got away
from the notion that there should be
certain social stigmas now that plays
one way in in in the suburbs it plays
something very differently in the inner
city because the poor traditionally had
very few weapons against social
disintegration and one of the most
important weapons was the social stigma
that said it's wrong to drop out of
school it's wrong to father children
that you don't take care of it's wrong
to disdain taking a job because it's
only minimum-wage it's it's disgraceful
to become dependent those were social
stigmas they had a sense of shame to
them but in the 1960s we convinced one
another that the only great sin was to
be judgmental and we must not in any way
be judgmental and as Christopher Jenks
says once you remove is very very
prominent sociologist once you take away
that form of judged judgment in effect
they're tearing up the moral contract
and you leave the poor almost
defenseless against the normal
centrifugal forces of disillusion that
they face you write about Martin Luther
King right you say he had he changed
well I I write about him with great
admiration because I think that he at
least in the beginning understood very
clearly that you could fight for you
could fight against injustice it could
fight for human rights
without playing the victim card and he
wrote says listen you know really
because we have been the the object of
injustice does not mean that we can
abrogate responsibility for our own
abdicate responsibility for our own
lives to be self-reliant and he tried to
avoid assuming a moral tone that
basically said we are innocent everybody
else is guilty he was trying to build a
moral consensus and I think that
reflected the sort of the middle-class
value system of the southern black
leadership and the end of theology that
the sort of the Ghandi like a philosophy
that said that we're not going to
morally browbeat our foes that we're
going to emphasize our common humanity
and again that that famous phrase you
look forward to the day when his
children would be judged not by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character that vision I think
came as close as this country ever came
to binding us together in a moral
community and tragically I think that
was lost as the emphasis shifted to from
from that moral leadership to the sense
we are victims and we don't want equal
rights we want reparations and the
classification of people by skin color
you cite a poll in 1966 and you say well
white radicals were already declaring
King an anachronism the preacher
received an approval rating of 88
percent of the black Americans in
contrast black power advocate Stokely
Carmichael won the approval of only 19
percent wouldn't everyone and and that
is also that is a real paradox because I
think that the black community in this
country tends to be much more socially
conservative than they are given credit
for and that that often the media and an
experts like us we tend to turn towards
certain designated black spokesmen who
are supposed to speak for the black
community they don't always speak for
the black community you know for a while
there the Black Power advocates were
much more fashionable than Martin Luther
King but Martin Luther King's mixture of
faith and moral commitment and his
commitment to those values I think
always represented the average black
community far better than the radicals
why do we see such a resurgence of
Malcolm X and the popularity in among
the black
well again I'm not sure how much of the
resurgence that is it is it's again the
we see movies made about it we see
spokesman who have who have embraced it
but I'm not sure whether he whether if
you if you really did a survey who
represents the values most closely of
American blacks Malcolm X and Martin
Luther King my bet would be that Martin
Luther King would would win that
overwhelmingly got another book in you
why shouldn't I hope so what's it gonna
be a Braille I don't know I I'm I'm
interested in employ in exploring the
issue of the way we raise children and
more in depth give kids yes three hard
thing to do today it's extraordinarily
hard to do and I think that anybody
that's talked to parents understands the
the the pressures that it is to try to
raise children with a certain set of
values a certain set of beliefs a
certain character when faced with all of
the various pressures of society around
them and I certainly don't have any easy
answers for that are you happy the way
this book is being received well it's
just published just very very recently
thus far I'm quite pleased got a very
nice review from The Wall Street Journal
and one hopes that it will up that it
will spark a thoughtful debate about
these issues because it I think it
raises and touches on a number of
crucial points that have been in the
news quite a bit and hopefully will shed
more light than heat Charles J Sikes of
Milwaukee Wisconsin this is the book a
nation of victims the decay of the
American character by st. Martin's Press
thank you